hi I'm Ryan I'm going to be watching the
trailer for the Veronica Mars movie that
the big deal with Kickstarter and
everything and I've never seen the show
but I love Kristen Bell the things I
would do to her sexual things alright
let's get out Veronica Mars on damn
right it's been approved for the
company's featured in whatever you are
issued a private investigators license
for your 18th birthday what do you think
that says about a person compulsive
addictive personality but That's not me
anymore New York lawyer is destined for
greatness over my parents don't think
that I could have landed a creature such
as the one that I promised I'd and are
focusing their investigation on her
boyfriend at Logan Echolls I need your
help Veronica I don't really do that
anymore
what's this I specifically told the
agency an eager-to-please brunette dick
hey no no no what's happening yeah it's
still kind of new economy we are going
to the reunion I'm shocked you even came
to this I knew you'd be here you've been
sitting there since graduation haven't
you
Veronica Mars look who it is most likely
to vlog in class buzzkill you are just
who I was looking for most likely to
know where I can find the bar case file
how did you get this sure you know
breaking and entering is a felony come
on I knew the felonies before I knew the
state capitals so you're gonna ask I
wouldn't be here
America thinks he's guilty and that's
good enough for me I know Logan either
this quality but there's a darkness to
that kid there's just so much going on
here right now it's moving sexy it's big
just the tip of the iceberg everyone's
even taking Veronica whatever you're
doing just and down on me
don't you think that's got a bit old
original enough
yes here that bunch of [ __ ] in this
neighborhood I feel like I'd be more
excited for that film if I had been
familiar with the show otherwise it just
looks ok Kristen Bell oh yeah the amount
of times I had masturbated to her